-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
I hope everyone's
doin' well tonight
and let's get to the news.
Well, just this week,
we learned that women received
unnecessary hysterectomies
at a ICE detention facility,
the attorney general called
for demonstrators
to be charged with sedition,
and the White House wanted
to use a heat ray
on peaceful protesters to clear
the way for a photo op.
I think, at this point,
even Q is an undecided voter.
That's right, federals officials
reportedly considered deploying
a so-called heat ray
that makes targets' skin
feel like it's burning,
in preparation for clearing
a peaceful protest
across from the White House
in June.
Apparently, they decided
the ray was too much,
after testing it
on Steve Bannon.
[ Laughing ]
Looks like the heat ray
was accidently set to...
Multiple White House staffers
reportedly tested positive
yesterday for the coronavirus,
except for Stephen Miller,
who, thankfully,
wears a mask.
That's right,
multiple White House staffers
reportedly tested positive
yesterday for the coronavirus.
But don't worry.
They're downplaying it,
so he doesn't panic.
Former President Barack Obama
announced today
that the 768-page
first volume of his memoir
will be titled
the "Promised Land."
Seems really long, but remember,
most of that is pauses.
[ As Obama ]
Chapter, uh...
one!
[ Laughing ]
President Trump spoke today
at the White House Conference
on American History.
This year's theme was
"Doomed to Repeat Itself."
Barbados announced this week
that it will remove
Britain's Queen Elizabeth
as its head of state
and become a republic
by next year
and the British press
has already figured out
who to blame.
According to a new report,
leafy green produce
has been linked
to 40 serious E. coli outbreaks
from 2009 to 2018.
Wow, that stuff could
really kale you.
["kill"]
I guess eating leafy greens
escarole of the dice.
["is a roll"]
But, look, if you ate some,
just romaine calm
["remain"]
and lettuce hope it
["let us"]
doesn't happen again.
Also, sorry
if this joke gave you
an arugula heartbeat.
["irregular"]
You know, when I get the jokes,
I get the name
of who wrote them.
That one was written
by two writers.
Ian and Bryan had
to collaborate on that.
I'm assuming at a Whole Foods.
[ Laughs ]
Keep up the great work, guys.
I really miss seeing your faces.
[ Laughing ]
Finally --
And, finally,
the owners of Chuck E. Cheese
have petitioned
a Texas bankruptcy court
to allow them to destroy more
than seven billion prize tickets
that have piled up
in its supply chain
amid the coronavirus pandemic.
Seven billion tickets or,
if you convert that to prizes,
[ Laughing ]
one large bear.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.